we have an exclusive clip at next week's
episode and it's very Orion as R Us
centric rule number one never send me to
voicemail
ah hey good morning is it thank you for
having some serious nightmares last
night you're really tossing and turning
no I was probably just wrestled well I
think I have a solution to that take a
look at these ballroom dancing classes
yep
salsa tango wall - take your pick since
when do you like the dance
I don't but unless you want our first
dance together as a married couple to be
the electric slide I should probably
learn so when are you're free I will
sign us up um
I don't know I'm not really sure about
my schedule right now oh well I mean any
night you want they pretty much of
classes going yeah I just can't commit
okay I have to go okay well we'll figure
this out I actually have to gonna be
Jillian to talk about a press schedule
okay hey are you sure you're okay you're
not still upset with me no promise why
is she telling Ezra what's going on
I she's keeping him out of the dark
everybody else is like letting people in
there's their significant others handle
too it was Mona no Mona knows Emily told
Paige the whole baby situation
[Music]